14 years is a long time to wait but
Pixar and writer director Bradford have
finally brought audiences back to the
comic book inspired world of The
Incredibles like any good sequel it
doesn't tie up all of its plot threads
neatly at the end of its run time
there's no telling for sure if or when
we'll get a follow-up so let's take a
look at the most pressing unanswered
questions in Incredibles - where's the
Underminer Incredibles - picks up
exactly where the first movie left off
fourteen years prior with the PAR family
facing off against the Underminer the
battle rages on the ground and spills
into the streets as the heroes manage to
just barely save city hall when the dust
settles however the villain has escaped
and The Incredibles failure to apprehend
him kick starts the rest of the plot so
where has this nemesis vanished - the
only reference the movie makes to his
whereabouts come during the credits when
the silhouette of his drove vehicle can
be seen driving off into the proverbial
sunset more pressingly what is he going
to buy with his newly acquired Millions
what was Evelyn's end game Everland ever
reveals her motivation to Elastigirl in
exactly the kind of supervillain
monologue of the first Incredibles film
mocked and when I unleashed
hey Doug you got me MARTA lucky she
blames superheroes for the death of her
father who relied on the vigilantes even
after they were outlawed manipulating
her brother's sense of nostalgia she
intends to frame supers for a terrible
attack and ensure they remain illegal
forever after hypnotizing an entire
luxury yacht full of heroes and world
leaders Evelyn's escaped by plane more
the boat steers itself towards newer
berm while the rest of the assembled
super seize control of the boat
Elastigirl narrowly thwart Evelyn's
flight but if she hadn't what would the
villain have done go into hiding change
her name we may never know what's next
for the supers Incredibles 2 introduces
a large cast of never-before-seen
superheroes brought out of hiding by
winston Dever
as part of his PR campaign their scenes
ranked among the movies highlights the
real question is what will they do next
will void get to spend more time with
our Idol Elastigirl well crusher ever
truly uncrushed anything whatever the
future holds for each of them their
chemistry makes it nice to imagine that
they might form a team and continue
working together
maybe they'll lay the foundations for
some sort of avenging League of Justice
what will Jack Jack's power be speaking
of intriguing superhero combinations
it's impossible to discuss Incredibles 2
without bringing up Jack Jack whose
array of unpredictable abilities
provides many of the movie's most
memorable scenes when Bob Parr brings
his infant son to Edna mode to ask for
help she reminds him that many supers
manifest multiple powers early in life
before growing into their defining
characteristics
Jack Jack however has many more powers
unusual for his age and shows no sign of
settling into any of them by the story's
end he remains blessed with laser vision
flammability multiplicity
dimension-hopping and a rage triggered
beast mode the only question is what's
next for the combustible baby combustion
imminent
it means fire rapping what's honey like
the biggest missed opportunity in
Incredibles - might be the choice to
leave honey best better known as the
wife of Frozone off screen once again
the character became an instant fan
favorite in 2004 without even showing
her face as she refuses to tell for his
own where she put his super suit the
sequel spends more time with a personal
life of the Parmalee and their
friendship with uncle Lucius gets more
screen time as well but honey is once
again relegated to a cameo invoice only
as she shouts from across the apartment
suit up it might get weird I'll be there
how long until the next sequel
Incredibles 2 throws its audience right
back into the final scene of a movie
from nearly a decade and a half before
the gap is so remarkable that Pixar
prepared a special introduction with the
casting crew apologizing for the wait so
with all these lingering questions about
the Incredibles universe still hanging
in the air we have to ask just one more
will a third Incredibles ever
materialize and when considering how
long the second films fate remained
uncertain the future of the franchise is
just as in clear as ever thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love teh
[Music]